for the sake of simplicity let's assume
that the current conversion rate is six
Chinese when per one US dollar and at
that exchange rate China is exporting 50
million dollars worth of goods to United
States and the u.s. is exporting 20
million dollars worth of goods to China
so clearly there's a trade imbalance the
u.s. is importing 50 million dollars
worth of goods and it's exporting 20
million dollars worth of goods so that
has a 30 million dollar trade deficit
now in this situation the Chinese
manufacturer is going to have 50 million
dollars that it wants to convert from
the rich revenue in America and convert
that to Chinese currency the American
the American manufacturers want it going
to want to convert its UN into 20
million dollars so the supply of the
supply of dollars which is this 50
million right over here it's going to be
much greater than the demand which is
the 20 million dollars so in if the
currencies were allowed to float the
dollar would weaken the cost of the
dollar would go down its supply is so
much bigger than the demand but let's
say that the Chinese central bank does
not want that to happen so this is the
people's this is the People's Bank of
China they do not want they do not want
the currency the the Chinese currency to
strengthen because of that were to
happen then Chinese goods would become
more expensive in the United States it
would be harder to maintain this trade
imbalance they want it so what they do
is they essentially make up for the
difference in demand for the dollar
right here there's only demand for 20
million dollars their supply of 50 so
what they do is they create demand for
30 million dollars and the way that they
create demand for 30 million dollars at
that exchange rate is that they can
literally they can literally print
create 180 they can literally create 180
million un and then an exchange rate of
6 to 1 that would essentially and they
would go out there into the open markets
and try to convert this into dollars and
so this would create demand for an
incremental 30 million
dollars and so when they do that the
total demand for dollars is there 30
million plus the 20 million dollars from
the American manufacturer that will
completely equal the supply of dollars
at that exchange rate and so it will not
cause the exchange rate to fluctuate or
the balance of trade to change so this
is clearly a very simplified example so
much of the the actual numbers are much
larger than in the millions they're in
the they're in the hundreds of billions
of dollars but this gives at least in my
mind a respectable idea of how the
Chinese central bank is actually keeping
its currency pegged to the dollar and
how that's helping to maintain a trade
imbalance this is Salman Khan of the
Khan Academy for CNBC